bonjour à toutes et à tous bon jeu
auprès d'eric à bonjour j me notre
invité ce matin de mitiga bonjour
rongeurs vous êtes chargé de mission
pour l'opération pays propre organisée
principalement par l'association
entreprise environnement qui fédère
d'autres entreprises autour donc de
cette d'une action qui se veut
écologique
donc il s'agit de nettoyer donc la
martinique de trop de déchet encore qui
traînent dans la nature et qui polluent
c'est la 18e édition alors 18e édition
comment faut-il le voir ça de mitiga le
verre à moitié plein mais aussi à moitié
vide parce que ce qu'on aurait voulu
c'est qu'il n'y en ait plus l'opération
pays propre vous l'aviez déjà dit lors
de précédentes éditions et ça continue
voilà vous en êtes à votre 18e
exactement donc dix huitième opération
pays propre
nous sommes à plus de 1700 participants
donc c'est jamais arrivé il y a encore
deux en était à sept cents participants
et la 1701 donc alors ça aujourd'hui
quoi une prise de conscience conscience
ça c'est sûr beaucoup d'écoles donc
forcément il y a
un côté sensibilisation et puis
maintenant l'environnement les éco
gestes sont nommés dans les programmes
donc beaucoup plus d'écoles beaucoup
plus d'élèves beaucoup plus
d'entreprises beaucoup de plus de
particuliers donc oui à une prise de
conscience c'est sûr après est-ce qu'il
ya plus de déchets il y en aura toujours
malheureusement des déchets parce que
forcément il ya des chaires a mené par
la mer mais bon la mer a bon dos il a
également des personnes qui vivent en
martinique et qui sont et qui sont mal
progressé
et puis bon c'est bien mais arrêtez de
jeter c'est mieux voilà ça c'est ça
parce que des déchets bon à nature j'ai
envie de dire l'homme il en produit donc
le tout c'est de limiter le rejet de
beaucoup de ces déchets aussi dans la
nature quoi voilà c'est de gérer une
gestion des chefs dame ans que l'aînée
chèvre on est bien d'accord qu'à la base
quelqu'un les acheter en amont voilà
alors quelques chiffres quand même parce
que alors vous vous indiquer que un
martiniquais produit 5 123 kg de déchets
par an alors dit comme ça ça paraît
cette farce et notre jeu 100 mille
tonnes de déchets par an donc au global
global total à partir de 6 ans de petite
île justement de la martinique 200 mille
tonnes de déchets je sais pas si on se
rend compte de ce chiffre
alors ce qui est vraiment important
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de personnes
finalement qui qui ne savent pas donc on
a sa poubelle noir puis ensuite on jette
sa poubelle noir dans dans la poubelle
la voirie passe et puis à la poubelle
disparaît mais non elle est toujours là
alors quand je parle de poubelles noires
c'est à dire tout ce qui n'est pas
recyclé on est bien d'accord donc sa
part soit à l'incinérateur soit dans les
centres d'enfouissement et son
enfouissement c'est quoi c'est une
décharge c'est à dire un trou un cratère
et on met tous les déchets et on en est
on remet de la terre ce qui fait
finalement des montagnes de déchets et
en martinique il ya cinq centres
d'enfouissement donc concrètement il ya
trois montagnes de déchets en martinique
et si on ne recycle pas si on continue à
jeter à consommer on va bientôt avoir et
bien des déchets sous la terre de sur
toute la martinique
alors vous indiquer que lors des
éditions précédentes ce sont en moyenne
215 tonnes de déchets qui ont été
ramassées donc lors de ses opérations et
opérations et 15 tonnes par par
opération voilà alors vous disais que
c'était que plus de 200 entreprises bon
là vous avez 10700 sutton et pour cette
année là quelque part que des
entreprises ainsi que l'association ela
l'entreprise voilà et et vous parliez de
8700 bénévoles qui ont déjà par le passé
déjà sur d'autres opérations sur toutes
les opérations entreprises et plus de
8000 participants
ouais très bien alors dites moi alors on
a parlé des chiffres c'est est ce que
cette opération n'est pas aussi pour
beaucoup d'entreprises qui viennent
comme ça de se faire une bonne image
d'avoir un peu de notoriété et lors de
sept de ses deux trois jours parce que
ça dure un week-end on va y venir c'est
la semaine prochaine et puis le reste de
l'année
allez peuvent polluer alors je veux dire
l'estimé pas en bonne conscience
voyez ce que je veux dire voilà est-ce
qu'il ya un suivi est ce que vous vous
vous n'êtes pas là pour faire la police
évidemment mais est-ce que vous
encourager est ce que vous pourriez
suivre d'ailleurs accompagner ces
entreprises pour tout au long de l'année
quelle qu'elle soit vertueuse justement
de ce point de vue là parce que
peut-être des entreprises qui viennent
là opération pays propre et puis le
reste de l'année elles ne sont pas très
très attentive à la protection
d'environnement
déjà on justement dans cette opération
pays propre on ne met pas en valeur une
entreprise plus qu'une autre
il n'y a pas du tout ce côté une
notoriété s'est d'ailleurs beaucoup il
ya des entreprises qui nous propose de
financer des t-shirts avec leur logo et
un nouveau d'entreprises puisque c'est
pas du tout le but de cette opération
donc il s'agit pas de faire de la
publicité pour les entreprises ils
reviennent travailler avec nous vous
accompagnerons vallée nommé dans le
bilan qui a participé bien sûr mais il y
aura aucun logo sur nos t-shirts sur nos
casquettes ça c'est vraiment
le critère de cette opération et on veut
que ça reste comme ça
après oui il y à des entreprises qui
veulent agir pour l'environnement donc
ils vont ils vont participer à cette
opération après les accompagner c'est
une casquette justement deux entreprises
environnement on a plusieurs casquettes
de l'association entreprises
associations entreprises environnantes
pour laquelle je travaille donc c'est
une association plusieurs entreprises
martiniquaises sont adhérentes
combien est association 90 90 et donc
nous avons plusieurs casquettes la
première donc c'est entretenir entre
guillemets l'environnement c'est-à-dire
des espaces verts organisation de
l'opération pays propre sensibiliser
donc
aller dans les écoles pour sensibiliser
les écoles des des affiches
sensibilisation pays ne s'est pas en
pack cochon ça avait fait un petit peu
de bruit et également nous sommes les
représentants de plusieurs filières de
recyclage en martinique c'est à dire que
nous allons accompagner justement des
entreprises dans le recyclage de
plusieurs déchets électroménagers des
déchets électriques et électroniques
professionnels des pneus les meubles
c'est certain mais patrick alors les
entreprises très bien des bénévoles qui
participent et puis et puis il ya les
uns et les autres
federica ou moi il faut aussi qu'on
fasse des efforts individuellement pour
gérer nos déchets vous avez une formule
choc
d'ailleurs vous vous dites en martinique
l'île aux fleurs surnommée l'île aux
fleurs les déchets fleurissent plus vite
que les fleurs bon c'est vraiment une
formule choc mais mais bon voilà quoi
mais je regarde autour de nous c'est
vrai on va quand même plus de déchets
que de fleurs finalement aujourd'hui
qu'on va sur la plage
il n'y a pas un endroit où il n'y a pas
un déchet et quand je parle de déchets
je parle aussi du micro plastiques de du
bouchon de petites particules en
plastique et si c'est également des
déchets 1 et qui font beaucoup qui ont
des conséquences catastrophiques sur
l'écosystème
donc ça participe de ça aussi ce type
d'opération parce que bon alors on va en
venir justement à ce qui se fait
concrètement sur le terrain donc en fait
vous ce que je voulais parler d' arrêter
ça vous savez vous avez inciter les uns
et les autres
bon certains ont dit que c'était presque
une forme de délation mais en tout cas à
signaler les lieux pas forcément à
dénoncer quelqu'un m'a signalé les lieux
où il ya des dépôts d'ordures sauvages
avec ses textes et vous continuez cela à
la cette application en effet c'est
s'est vraiment montré m'a regardé il ya
eu un malpropre qui a déposé
oui donc ça c'est un individu les
voisins et qui que vous m'avez visité
lumière les malpropres qui a et c'est
peut-être comme ça on arrêtera de
trouver des décharges sauvages de
trouver des frigos dans les ravines
donc oui on y lit à une forme de
dénonciation puisqu'il faut arrêter de
jeter ses déchets n'importe où donc ça
descend oui bien sûr ça compte mais
voilà alors je disais donc entreprises
environnement 18e opération pays propre
ce sera donc les 11 vendredi 11 samedi
12 et dimanche 13 octobre soit le week
end de la semaine prochaine et donc
comment ça se passe donc certaines
entreprises choisissent des lieux c'est
ça un petit peu c'est une grosse
frustration parce que ramasser des
déchets gros bas après les chefs font
les acheminer quelque part on essaie de
tri au maximum les pneus la ferraille
les frigos les bouteilles en plastique
tout ça ne va pas aller au même endroit
donc pendant un mois
tout le monde peut s'inscrire les
inscriptions sont terminées et en
parallèle nous cherchons des sites pour
accueillir ces personnes
donc après le but c'est pas d'aller
ramasser les déchets de monsieur x qui
l'a jeté devant chez lui on va pas mais
on va donc bien sûr essayer de nettoyer
des décharges sauvages des plages voilà
vraiment des déchets en conséquence et
qui sont là depuis des années et donc ce
sont des équipes d'entreprises qui
viennent qui se mettent ensemble d'une
sorte de brigade quoi un petit peu de
l'environnement alors après 35 jours par
exemple il ya des sites
il va avoir 150 personnes donc des
associations des particuliers des
entreprises
donc voilà sur chaque site en fait donc
là il ya un peu plus de 20 sites
il faut regarder déjà quels types de
déchets il ya combien de personnes je
peux m quel type de personne puisqu'il
ya des enfants je ne peux pas les mettre
sur certains sites et des personnes au
contraire qui aime qui ont des gros bras
et qui aime les gros déchets donc voilà
il ya toute une logistique en amont
merci domitilla de nous avoir évoqué
donc parler de cette dix huitième
opération pays propre du week-end de la
semaine prochaine organisée donc on le
rappelle par l'association entreprise
environnement vous êtes chargé de
mission donc pour l'organisation de
cette opération on vous souhaite une
bonne journée et une bonne opération
pays propre également voilà et puis une
bonne journée aussi à nos auditrices et
auditeurs